Esta es una tira cómica reciente de Los Angeles Times.
¿El remate?
"Por otro lado, no tengo que levantarme a las 4
cada mañana para ordeñar a mi labrador."
Esta es una portada reciente de la revista New York.
Los mejores hospitales donde los doctores irían a tratarse por cáncer,
nacimientos, golpes, cardíopatías y reemplazos de caderas: la sala de emergencias a las 4 a.m.
Y este es un popurrí musical que hice...
(Música)
¿Se han dado cuenta que las 4 de la mañana se ha convertido
en una especie de información invisible?
Significa algo como que estás despierto a la peor hora posible
(Risas)
Tiempo de inconvenientes, percances y ansiedades.
Tiempo de planear cómo liquidar al Jefe de Policia,
como en la clásica escena de "El Padrino".
El guión de Coppola describe a estos tipos como "exhaustos en manga corta.
Son las cuatro de la mañana".
(Risas)
Un momento para cosas aun más lúgubres,
como autopsias y embalsamamientos descriptos por Isabel Allende
en "La Casa de los Espíritus".
Después de que la hermosa Rosa es asesinada,
los doctores la preservan con ungüentos y pastas fúnebres.
"Trabajaron hasta las cuatro de la mañana."
Un momento para cosas aun más lúgubres que eso,
como en la revista New Yorker de Abril.
Esta pequeña pieza de ficción de Martin Amis
empieza así: " El 11 de Septiembre de 2001, él abrió sus ojos
a las 4 a.m en Portland, Maine
y el último día de Mohamed Atta comenzó"
Para una hora que considero la más plácida
y la más calma del día, las 4 de la mañana seguro tiene
muy mala prensa
(Risas)
en diferentes medios y según grandes autores.
Y me hizo sospechar.
Pensé: seguramente las mentes más creativas del mundo, en realidad,
no se remitirían a esta simple metáfora
como si la hubieran inventado ¿cierto?
¿Podría estar sucediendo algo más ahí?
Algo deliberado, algo secreto.
¿Y quién comenzó a rodar la injuria de las cuatro de la mañana?
Yo digo que fue este tipo: Alberto Giacometti, que aparece acá
con algunas de sus esculturas en un billete de 100 francos suizos.
Lo hizo con su famosa pieza
del Museo de Arte Moderno de Nueva York.
Su título: " El Palacio a las Cuatro de la mañana",
(Risas)
1932.
No es sólo la referencia críptica más antigua
que pude encontrar de las cuatro de la mañana.
Creo que esta presunta primera escultura surrealista
puede resultar una increíble clave a virtualmente
cada expresión artística de las 4 de la mañana que le siguió.
Lo llamo "El Código Giacometti", en exclusiva para TED.
No, siéntanse libres de seguirme en sus Blackberries
o sus iPhones si los tienen.
Es más o menos así: esta es una búsqueda reciente en Google
sobre las cuatro de la mañana.
Los resultados varían, por supuesto. Esto es bastante usual.
Los diez primeros resultados te entregan
cuatro referencias a la canción de Faron Young, "Son las 4 de la Mañana",
tres referencias a la película de Judi Dench, "Las Cuatro de la Mañana",
una referencia al poema de Wislawa Szymborska, "Las cuatro de la mañana".
Y pueden preguntarse: ¿qué tienen en común una poetisa polaca, una Dama británica,
y un cantante country del salón de la fama,
aparte de este excelente ranking en Google?
Bueno, comencemos con Faron Young, quien casualmente, nació
en 1932.
(Risas)
En 1996 se disparó en la cabeza el 9 de diciembre,
que casualmente resulta ser el cumpleaños de Judi Dench.
(Risas)
Pero no murió el día en que Dench nació.
Languideció hasta la tarde siguiente, cuando finalmente sucumbió
a un disparo presuntamente auto-inflingido a la edad de 64,
que, casualmente, es la edad que Alberto Giacometti tenía al momento de morir.
¿Dónde estaba Wislawa Szymborska durante todo esto?
Ella tenía la coartada más irrebatible de todas.
Porque el 10 de diciembre de 1996, mientras el Señor Cuatro de la Mañana,
Faron Young, estaba estirando la pata en Nashville, Tenessee,
la Señora Cuatro de la Mañana -o una de ellas de cualquier forma- Wislawa Szymborska
estaba en Estocolmo, Suecia, recibiendo el Premio Nobel de Literatura.
Exactamente 100 años después de la muerte de Alfred Nobel.
¿Coincidencia? No, espeluznante.
(Risas)
La coincidencia, para mí, tiene una magia más simple.
Es como si yo dijera:
"¿Sabías que el Premio Nobel fue instaurado en 1901,
que casualmente, es el mismo año en el que nació Alberto Giacometti?"
No, no todo calza tan perfectamente en este paradigma,
pero eso no significa que no esté sucediendo algo raro
al más alto nivel.
De hecho hay gente en este salón
que quizás no quiera que muestre el video que están a punto de ver.
(Risas)
Video: "Tenemos cancha de tenis, piscina, sala de cine...
O sea que si quiero chuletas, aún en medio de la noche,
¿tu sirviente me las freirá?
Claro, para eso se le paga.
¿Necesitas toallas, lavandería, sirvientes?
Espera, espera, espera. Déjame ver si entendí.
Es Navidad, son las 4 a.m.
Hay rugidos en mi estómago.
Homero, por favor."
Espera, espera, espera.
Déjame ver si entendí bien, Matt. (Groening)
(Risas)
Cuando Homero Simpson necesita imaginarse
el más remoto momento posible, no sólo del reloj,
sino de todo el bendito calendario ¿se le ocurren las 4 de la mañana
en el nacimiento del niño Jesus?
Y no, no sé cómo encaja
en el intrigante esquema de las cosas, pero obviamente
reconozco un mensaje en clave cuando lo veo.
(Risas)
Dije que reconozco un mensaje en clave cuando lo veo.
Y amigos, pueden comprar una copia del libro de Bill Clinton "Mi Vida"
aquí, en la librería de TED.
Busquen página tras página cuantas referencias ocultas quieran.
O pueden ir al sitio web de Random House donde está este extracto.
Y ¿cuánto creen ustedes que tenemos que leer
para encontrar el premio?
¿Me creerían que sólo doce párrafos?
Esta es la página 474 en sus libros, si es que me siguen:
"A pesar de que estaba mejorando, aún no estaba satisfecho
con el discurso inaugural.
Mis guionistas deben haber estado histéricos
porque mientras trabajábamos entre las una y cuatro de la mañana
del Día Inaugural, yo aún lo estaba modificando."
Seguro que sí, porque te has preparado toda tu vida
para este evento histórico que simplemente te ocurre de golpe.
Y luego,
(Risas)
tres párrafos más adelante, obtenemos esta belleza:
"Regresamos a la Casa Blair para revisar el discurso por última vez.
Había mejorado bastante desde las 4 a.m."
Y bueno, ¿cómo pudo hacerlo?
Según sus escritos, el hombre estaba dormido,
en una reunión de oración con Al y Tipper o aprendiendo a lanzar
un misil nuclear desde una maleta.
¿Qué les ocurre a los presidentes americanos a las 0400 en su primer día?
¿Qué le ocurrió a William Jefferson Clinton?
Quizás nunca lo sabremos.
Y me he dado cuenta que de hecho no esta hoy aquí
para enfrentar preguntas complicadas.
(Risas)
Podría ser incómodo ¿verdad?
Después de todo, todo este asunto ocurrió durante su turno.
Pero si él estuviera acá
(Risas)
nos podría recordar, tal como lo hace al final de su autobiografía,
que en este día, Bill Clinton comenzó un viaje-
un viaje que lo vió convertirse
en el primer presidente demócrata electo
por dos períodos consecutivos en décadas.
En generaciones.
El primero desde este hombre, Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
quien comenzó su propio viaje sin predecentes
hace mucho, en su primera elección;
hece mucho, en un tiempo más simple; hace mucho, en 1932-
(Risas)
el año en que Alberto Giacometti
hizo "El Palacio de las Cuatro de la Mañana".
El año en que, recordemos, esta voz, que ya se marchó,
vino a este enorme mundo de locos.
(Música)
(Aplausos)